das feld noch mal eine ecke besser ist
aber um spiel selbst ist auch wirklich
ein guter spieler den man nicht
überschätzen sollte
beide haben sie sich wirklich ein
fauxpas geleistet das war aber schon
ganz wird sicherlich persönlich nicht
erwartet und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge microsoft heute wo wir
mal etwas ausprobieren was ich bisher
noch nicht gemacht habe das ist eine
neue format idee die mir letztens kam
und ich würde euch gerne mal bitten euch
zuschauer schreibt einfach ganz
ungebunden direkt in die kommentare was
ihr denkt ihr könnt auch schreiben ob er
das gut schlecht
scheiße whatever findet und auch an alle
anderen youtuber kollegen die das sehen
solltet ihr zu dem thema als irgendeine
finanzierte meinung haben schreibt die
einfach gerne mal rein
ich werde jetzt einfach jede emotionale
wertung für die kommentare ausblenden
und das einfach alles mal sachlich sehen
ok dann kommen wir zum thema selbst zum
gegenstand dieser serie
und zwar habt ihr wahrscheinlich im
titel irgendwas in richtung kommentare
oder so gelesen ich hatte nämlich
gestern die idee dass diese news formate
ja irgendwie nicht mehr so cool sind und
keiner will auch dass dir die das andere
youtuber das eigene video material
verwenden ich wollte das übrigens auch
nicht und dass der anreiz zum schauen
der der ursprünglichen videos noch
besteht
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht okay
wie kann man das machen wie kann man das
noch vielleicht mit minecraft spielen
verbinden was sich ja sonst immer mache
und hab ich mir gedacht ja okay dann
machen wir doch mal einfach so eine art
navarro commentary und gucken mal wie
das bei euch ankommt deswegen habe ich
auch gesagt dass ihr das gerne rein
schreiben könnt weil ich ab davon
absolut abhängig mache das belebt er hat
überlebt ok sack mais kommt der comic
con te
der effekt der schwester der schönen
dann lasst uns aber auch direkt loslegen
leute ich hab mir das so vorgestellt
ich schaue mir immer drei folgen an also
das heißt ich denke nicht alle folgen ab
ihr solltet und könnte auch immer auch
die folgen bei allen anderen teams
schauen ich schon mal nur drei folgen an
die ich jetzt besonders cool fand oder
die mir einfach ins auge gefallen sind
dann kommentiere ich die für euch ohne
genau zu sagen was passiert ist
ganz grob und verlinkt die für euch der
beschreibung dass ihr dann genau danach
schauen können ok als allererstes habe
ich natürlich wie sicher viele andere
auch mir heute die
folge von team mit sixx angeschaut wir
reden als über die vierte folge in
dieser vierten folge ist bei team mit 70
einiges passiert die hatten eigentlich
einen plan und zwar wollten sie daraus
dass recht viele leute einen strike
bekommen haben kapital schlagen und sich
das tanzen machen wie kann man sich
vielleicht auch denken nämlich indem man
diejenigen angreift allerdings ergaben
sich dabei ein paar schwierigkeiten
welche das sind das seht ihr in deren
folge und jetzt bitte nicht meinen
keller staub und freunde treffen
wichtiger denn je den herforder muss
erst mal okay es gab da auf jeden fall
ein kleines problem so ich denke mal es
wird in chronologischer reihenfolge auch
der erste linke der beschreibung sein
also schaut da gerne mal nach
man kann nur soviel sagen jetzt ist er
damit hinter mir
die jungs sind echt gut dabei also
diesen echt gut dabei so viel kann man
sagen die sind wirklich wirklich
wirklich weit also schaut er gerne mal
rein und gucken sondern bist echt nervig
kann es sein die hat kommen die
auftritte down dankeschön ersten okay
mord ist nämlich auch hinterm um die
ecke und macht es andere was kann man
jetzt ihr euch noch erzählen aus erfolg
ich hab meine notizen gemacht zu den
jeweiligen folgen die habe ich gar von
einem zweiten bildschirm offen es war
auf jeden fall richtig kritisch man kann
so viel sagen dass diese teams von
crafter und hallodri waren also team
erste folge tod wenn ich das richtig
sehe delay der wirt der das überbleibsel
von team verzögerter tumor und paletten
reville ist im chaos wg also die drei
teams hatten in strike und sind damit
ins fadenkreuz von team six geraten
was genau passiert ist seht ihr wie ich
schon gesagt habe mit dem obersten link
in der folge bzw
der oberste die oberste verlinkte folge
ist das genau
ich habe nochmal dazu für euch dass er
das auch finde ok dann geht es weiter
mit der zweiten folge die ich mir
angeschaut habt das ist team aus it
beziehungsweise hautnah ist er nur noch
hauptstadt ist nämlich auch das team was
ja mich und carlos war aus gekickt hat
er hat und das haben wir wirklich
ja das hat uns echt schon mitgenommen
müssen wir sagen das haben wir auch
schon mal thematisiert aber ich muss
sagen ganz ehrlich kompliment der
spielstil von hautnah der nur noch
alleine in faro ist nachdem sein team
partner durch ihn richtig krassen
creeper getötet wurde also so viel
schaden hätte ich auch nie erwartet dass
ein krieg gemacht
jetzt ist hauptmann alleine aber der
spielt es echt gut und sehr unterhaltsam
und vor allen dingen auch mutig und
risikofreudig der hat nämlich versucht
ebenfalls die teams mit den
offengelegten koordinaten also nochmal
rochat erste folge tod nämlich und die
erste folge tod verzögerte tumor und das
drehte chaos wg zu kneipen aber auch bei
haubner haben sich der probleme ergeben
welche das sind seht ihr wiederum mit
den links der beschreibung das ist
diesmal der zweite link genauen nein er
hat einfach nein er hat aber die bessere
rüstung was hat dich nicht für rüstung
das okay ich hatte mich auch ganz
bewusst so gemacht aber einfach weiter
wir können einfach noch eine kleine
runde ko s gehen dranhängen will ich
sagen so ich da sind wir in der runde
chris g es ist noch einer zu uns
gestoßen und zwar der markt derart neben
mir gesagt komm ich in der partie der
mod ich nehme mir heimat und dann
spielen jetzt aber diese runde als team
ksg runder und ich hab ein bisschen
struggle don't give me don't kill me
please
ich wollte noch was sagen und zwar roche
pfeile immerhin und zwar hat sich
behaupten auch noch was richtig
seltsames in der folge ereignet also da
gab es so ein wtf moment irgendwas
irgendwas merkwürdige selbst da ist er
lang gelaufen hat es etwas was
merkwürdiges passiert was ich mir
persönlich auch nicht erklären konnte
vielleicht habt ihr eine idee was das
ist oder wie das zustande kommen kann
wie gesagt zweiter linke goa alles klar
ich habe probleme die sind richtig viele
wie heißt du wärst schon mal in punkten
cs alt ob sie sich so viele bin ich
unsichtbar mich keiner an angetan ich
werde geehrt der ok sehr schön und dann
kommen wir doch einfach mal zur dritten
folglich übermitteln die chest die
dritte folge die ich mir angeschaut hat
und der dritte folgen denkt in der
beschreibung ist die von facebook
da habe ich auch noch mal kurz
reingeschaut da hat sich also simon
einen kleinen ganz lustigen fehler
erlaubt welcher das ist das seht ihr
dann unter dem dritten link da ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass sie das besser wissen
muss ich wirklich sagen gerade so ein
team was eigentlich extrem kompetent ist
vor allem im pvp faison ist ja nicht nur
gehabt und er es auch wirklich wirklich
gut
das haben jetzt auch schon verschiedene
leute gesagt und um gespielt eigentlich
auch ein recht guter spieler wie ich
persönlich finde ein guter ich denke
schon ich denke schon dass fans noch mal
eine ecke besser ist aber um spielt
selbst auch wirklich ein guter spieler
den man nicht überschätzen sollte aber
da haben sie sich wirklich ein fauxpas
geleistet
das war schon ganz wird sicherlich
persönlich nicht aber wie gesagt ihr
seht unter dem dritten folgen link und
die haben auch noch einige ganz
angenehme dinge gefunden was meinst du
wir sind im finale nur noch wie beide
leute wie gesagt ich sage es nochmal
seid so nett und schaltet einfach alles
was ich euch jetzt ein feld in die
kommentare ihr könnt aber seit sachlich
also wenn ihr findet das ist irgendwie
uncool weil man da jetzt nichts mehr zu
machen sollte wenn man
irgendwie ausgeschieden ist wenn ihr das
meint könnte es gerne rein schreiben
oder wenn ihr findet ja das ist eine
coole sache weil ich nicht spoiler
sondern quasi auf die spannenden folgen
hinweise meine eigene sich darauf
preisgebe
dann schreibt man das auch in die
kommentare ich richte mich da jetzt
wirklich mal ganz nach euch so eine
sache zu sagen also team six hat
wirklich das wollte ich noch anmerken
echt heftiges equipment echt heftiges
equipment in folge vier schon ungefähr
so viel was andere teams vielleicht in
ben dewar o2 in folge 10 hatten die
gelegen auf jeden fall gut vor die
nutzer ihrer zeit gut aber das macht ihm
steckt bleibt auch so dann lasst uns
jetzt noch ein bisschen spielen okay
machen wir es war kein match
konzentrieren ist richtig dass wir zum
lager modus jetzt muss ich wissen
spielen okay gut aussehen ja genau also
den unterschied machen die kommen wollte
ja genau was der finger hastig primax
max ist über sein handy max hatten 15
epping über sein handy wlan
ich habe zehn abgehende auf 5
millisekunden unterschied 50 prozent
okay leute schreibt eure meinung in die
kommentare
wir sind bei der nächsten folge wieder
haut rein macht's gut und und das auch
gerne für wort für den essen soll es
dass der oberst aloys